all right
not to dive into your the uh stereotype
of who people think you are
having a lot of beef dealing with a lot
of ops
currently
vladimir putin is invading ukraine yeah
you know have you you've been paying
attention yeah gas prices are [ __ ] up
right now [ __ ] though i just i just saw
850 in [ __ ] west hollywood i i was i
almost threw up in my mouth
it cost me 160 to fill up my suv yeah
terrible uh
you're the president of the united
states how are you handling putin if who
if julio julio is the president
how are you handling this [ __ ]
we need trump back in that [ __ ]
real [ __ ] trump i would have did what i
had to do in war
you can't just
you can't it's basically like extortion
you can't just distort people because
you feel like a vulnerable or you want
to take back over what they got going on
you want them back under your control so
i feel like it's like you plan on on a
week you know what i'm saying but i feel
like he's going to go to jail for war
crimes
i saw something like that
so if it were up to you you would never
have gotten rid of trump yeah i would
have kept trump trump was with all the
trump gangster
like he was with all the [ __ ] yeah i
would have kept trump in the office for
sure
and a lot of people a lot of people had
that ppp and that edd off of trump
yeah what a cat trump officer